hey neighbor hello
hey ian sally you're looking you're
looking great at night
thanks you doing anything tonight
no not really
wants valentine's day you sure you don't
have any plans yeah i know
that's depressing we should do something
really well i can just go in and take a
shower real quick
and then i'll i can hang out oh no no
not not tonight
i have plans besides i want to go on a
date with you
didn't you know i'm gay
sally yes yes
those are the words that are going to be
coming out of your mouth repetitively
you are in for a show there's this video
but before i say that i just want to say
you look very sexy
tonight ask me why i think that ask me
why out of all nights
i think tonight you finally look sexy
i just saw on pornhub.com
the best redhead porn man has ever seen
i swear it is comparable to when
christopher columbus found america
it was [ __ ] phenomenal okay these two
red head chicks
and then there was like this like
it like dealt with animals it was really
weird but anyway it was really hot at
the same time and one of them looked
exactly like you
which got me thinking two roommates just
one night
i mean you don't look like you got
anyone right
i hope you get your dick cut off why do
you want my dick cut off so
badly every [ __ ] night
why so i can feed it to the animals [ __ ]
the animal
don't let them in don't let them see
be the good girl you always have to be
this reminds me of that porno with the
two redheads
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you it's not
my period
kindred no
no one is available well now they
know let it go
let it go
let the singing go
oh hey i hope you know i was joking
about that whole
gay thing earlier i was wondering if you
still want to hang out tonight
oh yeah sure but um
that joke was horrible well
i was hoping that a date with me would
be able to make up for that
you won't be getting it tonight ian
sally's on her period you [ __ ]
get all the baggage